when it comes to popular movies
everyone's got theories there's just
something so gratifying about diving
deep into the finest details of a film
and coming up with a plausible
connection others haven't yet seen even
more exhilarating are those times when
those theories are eventually confirmed
by the people involved in a project in
the case of these cinematic conjectures
fans were able to figure out certain
connections long before they were
ultimately confirmed by those in the
know and as always beware the spoilers
the Logan prophecy 2013's the Wolverine
might have seemed like just another
installment of Logan's long history on
the big screen but as one fan on Twitter
noticed the film's clairvoyant character
Yukio predicted Logan's ultimate fate I
saw you die you see you on your back
there's blood everywhere holding your
own heart in your head at the end of
Logan of course that's almost exactly
what happened a few years later the
character died in the movie Logan while
lying on his back and covered in blood
as was foretold and while he wasn't
holding his literal heart in his hand he
was clasping the hand of his cloned
daughter Laura aka x-23 the connection
was not a coincidence director james
mangold later praised the person who
first drew the connection between the
scenes and thus confirmed it was his
intention all along but it should agree
with your observation cars take over
while most people wouldn't think too
deeply about a Pixar movie stirring
talking automobiles some adults and
maybe even some kids left screenings of
cars with a disturbing thought where are
the humans after all it's not like
humans never inhabited the world of cars
proof of human existence is littered
throughout the entire movie from door
handles to road signs and more so what
exactly happened to us
one fan theory proposed that the cars
themselves eliminated humans and as it
turns out that's actually what happened
according to Jay Ward the creative
director of the Cars universe the
anthropomorphic autos simply didn't need
the dead weight he said imagine in the
near future when the cars keep getting
smarter and smarter and after one day
they just go why do we need human beings
anymore they're just slowing us down
it's just extra weight
let's get rid of them but the car takes
on the personality of the last person
who drove it there you go
who knew a global robot domination story
could be so kid-friendly the frozen
Tarzan connections when frozen
co-directors Jennifer Lee and Chris buck
took to Reddit for an ask us anything
they blew everyone's minds when they
revealed that despite the film's opening
montage Anna and Elsa's parents didn't
actually die at sea instead buck stated
the protagonist parents got washed up on
a shore in a jungle island the Queen
gave birth to a baby boy they built a
tree house they get eaten by a leopard
that sounded a lot like what some fans
had theorized about the backstory of the
orphan tarzan and how he might actually
be the long-lost brother of Anna and
Elsa
buck later confirmed to MTV that fans
were right on the money with their
origin theory at least when it comes to
how the story plays out in his head he
explained of course
Anna and Elsa's parents didn't die yes
there was a shipwreck but they were at
sea a little bit longer than we think
they were because the mother was
pregnant and she gave birth on the boat
to a little boy they get shipwrecked and
somehow they really washed way far away
from the Scandinavian waters and they
end up in the jungle they end up
building a tree house and a leopard
kills them so the baby boy is raised by
gorillas so in my little head Anna and
Elsa's brother is Tarzan
it's too bad Tarzan didn't inherit his
sister's gift for whipping up ice
sculptures to help his jungle pals
beat the heat but at least the director
didn't come out and tell fans to let it
go and stick to the elephant's wild
theory you know I've been thinking
lately that maybe tossing could be some
subspecies of elephants
elephant the genie peddler another
Disney animation theory that's gotten
the official thumbs up is that the genie
from Aladdin appeared in the film long
before the street rat ever rubbed that
magic lamp fans noticed the peculiar
behaviors of the peddler who introduced
the movie and figured out that he and
the genie were the same guy now free
from the confines of the lamp do not be
fooled by his commonplace appearance
like so many things it is not what is
outside but what is inside that counts
director Ron Clements later admitted the
theory was true and said that was the
whole intention originally we even had
that at the end of the movie where he
would reveal himself to be the genie
and of course Robin Williams did the
voice of the peddler just through story
changes and some editing
we lost the reveal at the end so that's
an urban legend that actually is true
look at me from the side do I look
different to you spider-man's true MCU
debut there's been a long-running theory
amongst fans of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that Peter Parker showed up
even earlier than Captain America Civil
War as the story goes the little kid who
dressed like Iron Man and mean-mugged a
robot at the stark Expo in Iron Man 2 is
actually a young Peter Parker Iron Man 2
was released in 2010 after all and
everyone's favorite neighborhood web
slinger was still in his mid-teens in
2017
spider-man homecoming furthermore the
affer mentioned stark Expo takes place
in Parkers hometown of Queens Tom
Holland himself has now confirmed this
idea as MCU official the actor who plays
Spidey told Huffington Post it is Peter
Parker I can confirm that as of today I
literally had a conversation with Kevin
Feige only 20 minutes ago maybe I've
just done a big old spoiler but it's out
there now it's cool I like the idea that
Peter Parker has been in the universe
since the beginning
sup guys wait a minute you guys aren't
the real Avengers
I can tell hope gives it away Stanley is
a watcher anyone who regularly watches
Marvel movies is undoubtedly accustomed
to the regular Stanley cameos the comic
book legend is made an appearance in
almost every Marvel movie ever made
look at mr. smiles over him Lee's cameos
have always been written off as merely
nods to Marvel's main man but some fans
suspected he might be one of the
watchers a race of aliens who observe
and compile information on everything
the universe has to offer while
refraining from interference Lee himself
denied the period first
at minimum
but guardians of the galaxy vol 2
director James Gunn decided to have a
little fun and make the theory legit in
the 2017 film Gunn added a post-credits
scene in which Lee wriggles the watchers
with stories of his adventures how I get
out of here hey
RG I've got so many more stories to tell
ah guys oh gee the director then told
Radio Times there's a lot of cool stuff
that the fans come up with a lot of
stuff I don't agree with but I find the
idea that Stan Lee is a watcher or that
he works for the Watchers is just a fun
little nods of the fans thanks to those
fan suggestions Stan Lee's stellar role
in the MCU is now official
you know I guess one person can make a
difference
enough said
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]